what is up
reject nation here we go kevin feige
reportedly has a little response here uh
regarding the whole scarlet johansson
suing
disney uh over the black widow release
just the super quick super short recap
of the situation is that scarlett
johansson is claiming in the lawsuit
that this movie contractually is
supposed to have an exclusive theatrical
release meaning only in the theaters
and that uh they breached their contract
by putting it on
a dual strategy release with disney plus
and that there was an
email exchange so yeah that's the part
about an and the statements that were
released
they were saying that they talked about
an email i don't know if it's in the
contract
that's something we have to all keep in
mind 99.99 of us
who are tuning into this news and
whatever no matter how great of a
breakdown someone might give on this
they're not lawyers
most people aren't most women have a law
degree and most of us
don't know what the actual contract
itself
says right now so a lot of this is
becoming public but there's still
so much more that we do not actually
know what is written down typed up
what was signed everything like that but
basically
part of the email exchange is that if
there is to be some changes with the
releasing since so much of this is based
off of scarlett johansson earning money
her team also earning money off of
uh box office points and whatnot that
there should be renegotiation
so that said there was an email exchange
didn't say that was in the contract
right email from 2019 right right
exactly and then
you know sometimes in court that might
constitute as part of
a legal agreement just because it was
said in email but you know that's what i
mean this is a whole bunch of
areas here to unpack this is why this is
a big thing by the big deal
and then of course disney responded uh
the day that all this broke which was
yesterday saying that they didn't breach
any contract whatsoever
yeah like where we basically stand uh
amongst all this and there are people
who've done some great breakdowns like
i think uh john campia and grace
randolph from beyond the trailer
who are best friends from my
understanding they love each other what
they want
both want to be lumped into the same
sentence all the time
but those two uh they've given some
pretty great breakdowns a lot of people
were especially recommending grace
randolph's uh
our way and i did listen to them and
they are wonderful but where we
basically stand on the whole gist of a
situation even after hearing disney's
response
is that if scarlett johansson's
statements are to be believed or her
team statements are to be believed
that if they are supposed to enter
renegotiation if they did not discuss
prior to the dual strategy release or
renegotiate after like
there was no communication about that
whatsoever if they were actually like
ghosted in the way they were saying yeah
that is completely
messed up so with all this though and a
lot of people were wondering like what
did kevin feige have to say
what was kevin feige's thoughts on this
because scarlett johansson's
lawsuit is against disney themselves not
necessarily
marvel i know marvel is part of disney
but this is
towards disney so according to the
hollywood reporter editor
matthew baloney sounds like an italian
man
feige apparently lobbied disney to keep
black widow a theatrical only release to
not upset johansen
and then bologna reports feige is a
company man and prone to corporate
showdowns or
shouting matches but i'm told he's angry
and embarrassed
he lobbied disney against the
day-and-date plan for black widow
preferring the big screen
exclusivity and not wanting to upset his
talent
furthermore the report says that when
the [ __ ] hit the fan
the movie started tanking in johansen's
team threatened litigation
foggy tried to get disney to make right
with her
so if this is to be true because this is
coming from the editor over at hollywood
reporter and a lot of people are
running with this as if for sure this is
what feige is thinking and saying and
yada yada yada because hollywood
reporter for the most part can be a
reliable source
you know that's the hollywood reporter
this is to be true it sounds like he's
on the side where a lot of the fans
actually are right now you know he
obviously has a great
relationship with scarlett johansson uh
first is just an actress who was hired
for black widow
and then as a producing partner for this
movie and i don't blame kevin feige for
feeling this way it's
from the outside looking in it really
seemed like a lot of this has seemed
like feige
really wanted to just keep it for
theatrical release
as well and i think the last thing he'd
want
is for this situation to occur every
once in a while you hear
stories of like there's the marvel side
and feige running it and then he's
having some issues with the higher ups
at disney
and having to make this all work but
feige's most plugged in with his fans
and i feel like he's really
he has a strong relationship for him to
with scarlett johansson that i think the
last thing he'd
ever want is for her to feel cheated out
in some way that he would
want her to feel properly serviced
but john what's your take on what's
going on here so far yeah i mean this is
in line with
what was pitched yesterday in that they
said disney strong-armed marvel into
doing this
essentially i mean i don't know if kevin
feige and scarlett johansson spoke at
all behind the scenes it kind of doesn't
sound
like it so i'm curious to know what kind
of like muzzling or
restriction he might have been kept
under until this all broke and now it's
a mess and now there's at least a bit
more carte blanche for reports like this
to come out but uh yeah i don't blame
him at all for being upset and it does
seem like one of those things where yeah
if you're the leader of this ship and
you are
trying to attract this you know oscar
caliber of talent especially with your
actors who are going to be the face of
these characters yeah you don't want
this reputation of like you know i don't
have control enough to even make
you know sure that our parent company
honors their contracts and all that so
i'm not at all surprised that he would
be upset because i mean yeah
even though the movies and the universe
they built is bigger than just the
actors or whatever and i know there are
people out there who are like
don't you have enough money scarlett
johansson but it does
seem kind of like a shifty thing coming
from disney and if you look at the
report yesterday again we don't know
what's in
the actual contract but you know they do
kind of deflect or you can look at it
that way
being like we didn't breach contract and
like look at what was going on in the
world like we were just trying to be the
good guy when it doesn't really
preclude you from being able to also
talk to somebody
and say hey we need to do this and i
mean just from a personal level i
look at black widow the movie and i'm
like in a sense that could have been
released at any point on the phase four
timeline really i mean as much as people
gripe about its sort of isolated
feeling that could have helped the
theatrical release that much more and
had they had waited it could have been
much more of a success but they have
that post-credit scene john
that's right and then we can't get too
far into that storyline without showing
this tease otherwise people are going to
be like yeah we know
but uh yeah i'm very curious as to
how this is going to shake out because
obviously i mean you know marvel is a
gigantic asset to disney but also
a rift like this that's so public and so
ugly you know is not gonna just work out
peachy for everybody so
i'm curious to know what's gonna kind of
pan out from this
i mean like for me yesterday i was
reading the reports i was like okay
there's no way in hell
scarlett johansson ever has a chance of
like this this is putting her career on
the line like this is the most
the biggest studio in the world right
now who she's going toe to toe with and
she's getting a lot of credit
yeah absolutely like good for her for
going up against like the biggest studio
ever
but you know there's also the side of it
of like well if if her relationship with
feige is still good
maybe there's a chance of something
potentially ongoing
i mean that's regarded you know yeah
like only if her relationship with him
holds and i mean to his credit it sounds
like his
heart is in the right place on this one
and i don't know what action he can take
but at least you know
this isn't a direct quote you know this
is being sort of what i
what i'm hearing yeah but uh yeah that
is heartening to me because that's part
of the worry is like oh god is
is marvel down for this shady practice
too you know if the practice is in fact
shady as they say
yeah because i think that yesterday when
i when i i see it all
i saw plenty of it people being like
what did you expect from disney
of course there's the pandemic going on
this movie was delayed countless times
they
just can't pay for more marketing i'm
like that's not the point the why behind
them doing it the dual strategy that's
not
really what's in question is why they we
all know
why they did it yeah it's very
interesting it's very why they parent
why they
it's how they went about it and there's
a lot of things there's a lot of
contracts involved there's a lot of
players involved
and at the end of the day they should
have talked
with her and her team prior to deciding
to do this
or if they're going to make the decision
without talking with her they got to
renegotiate
to properly compensate her for
everything that she would have lost in
the box office revenue especially if it
was as
as adamant a a demand of theirs that it
be released theatrically i feel like if
that was a thing they were constantly
like
no we want to maintain this like you
can't how do you avoid that conversation
unless you try
yes um i mean they're saying here that
on the disney release
statement from yesterday that she's
earning money off of the premier access
thing but
like i said there's so much difference
of numbers and everything that we're
like well how much does she really want
reportedly it was 50 million there's
other reports saying that she wants to
be able to get residuals off of
anything that she's involved with that
is streaming on the
um on the disney plus you know anything
avengers related basically that she's
involved with which
this this lawsuit's a big deal because
this can open up a
whole can of worms not just for scarlet
scarlett johansson and disney but
everyone yeah anyone who's had their
movies simultaneously released
like this is a you know i imagine like
scarlett johansson's got
great lawyers she's scarlett johansson
um but i imagine disney's got to have
like the best lawyers
so yeah and they have infinitely more
money
to pay so as much as it's like about
billions versus the millions yeah i'm
still
like i'm kind of i'm rooting for
scarlett johansson it's just because
everything's just a crazy story yeah she
does walk out
like winning in some way you know it's
it's it's a long shot you know as much
as we all
feel what is right as much as we have
are our voice of public opinion
you know a lot of times it doesn't
freaking matter
they're not being like what do the
people want us to do in this case
but yeah guys leave your thoughts down
below on uh what you think what do you
think about what
kevin feige had to say what's your
thoughts on the situation so far
this is a fascinating tale to unpack
here and uh yeah we're along
for the journey and we'll still watch
marvel's what if we're still excited
yeah
i'm so excited for all that you know
separate art from the business
man all right guys leave your thoughts
down below and we'll talk with you soon
[Music]
you